let's go next to our caller oh we've got
someone from the 401 3 area code who's
calling today from four one three hey
that mean yes it is who's this oh this
is Tyler I'm originally from in
Belchertown Massachusetts but I live in
Washington DC now it is cool what's
going on I'm starting to hear a lot of
talk about how the government is going
to use the crisis in order to curtail
personal freedoms sort of like how the
Patriot Act was used and I don't know if
I'm just naive but I'm not super
concerned about that and it's just
wondering what your opinion on it is so
I think that here's the here's the so
there's some truth to it but it's not
really in the way that most people fear
so the way most people fear the
government using the coronavirus crisis
to curtail freedoms are the kind of
dystopian sci-fi you know ways of
monitoring people in ways that that
exceed what the current law allows or
you know people are talking about
martial law military in the streets and
all this type of stuff what they're
doing it they're already doing which is
for example court systems are not
functioning at full capacity so one of
the things that the Trump administration
is now asking for is that habeas corpus
which basically allow determines or
dictates people can't just be held
indefinitely without being charged or
tried right you've got it there has to
be a process that continues moving
forward reasonably quickly the idea is
hey listen courts can't really process
as much as they can normally because of
the virus so we should sort of just like
allow people to be indefinitely detained
even if we can't give them a trial
anytime soon that's being done like that
it's happening now so it is happening
it's just probably not in the exact way
that some people are fearful of yeah I
mean I think we definitely have to be
mindful of that but I'm hearing some
people using that as an excuse as to why
we shouldn't take this seriously and why
we shouldn't act more right no it's the
the solution is that's not the solution
the solution would be listen if the just
the system can't process people then
you're gonna have to just like let some
people go and then you know you're not
you're gonna have to maybe Rio pretend
them later and some people are gonna be
flight risks and you won't be able to
but it's incumbent upon the justice
system to provide that speedy trial and
you can't say well you just sit in jail
indefinitely so I think you're right
that there are people who are cynically
coming up with the wrong solution to
this problem but we want to make sure
that it doesn't get misused to minimize
how much we should all just be staying
the hell home absolutely well hey thanks
for answering my call have a great day
all right Tyler great to hear from you I
appreciate it